bonjour à tous je m'appelle daniel m de
la chambre de métiers de l'artisanat
je vous fait la bienvenue et vous
remercie de participer à cette 4e
édition de la journée découverte de
l'île et de la table organisé dans sa
relation de lutter et ses partenaires
la fa qui paie les milices de l'essonne
le départ du bâtiment du président or
ainsi que les apprentis d'auteuil du
lycée horticole et paysager de marquer
cinq rondes conférences que nous
proposons aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
la semaine nationale de l'apprentissage
sont consacrés à l'orientation des
jeunes vers l'est et de l'automobile la
fleuristerie de la beauté et du bâtiment
avant de commencer je voudrais juste
vous livrer quelques informations
importantes sur le secteur de
l'artisanat et deux sur l'apprentissage
y attirent de plus en plus de jeunes et
de personnes en reconversion cherchant à
exercer un métier qu'auprès du créatif
l'artisanat représente l'union face à
milan c est pour cela qu on appelle la
première moto
250 milles en 7 et 9 ans il déjà
affronté un livre en essonne un apprenti
ce droit est formé dans une entreprise
artisanale qui furent tous à voir avec
la formation en apprentissage ordre de
belle tape équipe d'avenir 80 % des
apprentis trouvent un emploi dans les
six mois qui suivent leur formation
c'est aussi l'opportunité d'envisager de
créer sa propre entreprise
41% des données en main facile
aujourd'hui ont été apportées voilà de
quoi alimenter nos discussions et
surtout nous espérons que ces
prélèvements suscitera des vocations
place maintenant à la présentation des
métiers de la beauté et du bien-être
autour de la table nous accueillons les
intervenants qui vont se présenter
bonjour je suis call of duty son
développement sur les formations en
relation un descriptif donc vraiment
vous nomme aussi sportives sont à
l'étude à travers les boutiques les
engrenages sa méthode des entreprises
dont les salons de vagues rien de les
articuler vont les accompagner dans nos
rayons
bonjour à l'excès la flamme des deux
formatrices pratique en esthétique et
j'accompagne les jeunes ans qui a fait
les brevets professionnels
il aura mon
bébé
bonjour
et nous rejoindra dans quelques minutes
cécile guéri mais d'artistes de la
capitale pour vous donner quelques
conseils ou bien de votre apprentissage
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions sur
le chat me répandre en fin de
présentation type pour votre information
f1 mosley
alors maintenant on va vous expliquer en
quoi qu'on dise que l'apprentissage de
l'amour disait
avec un diplôme à la clé un mythe ya ce
sens de la faculté des métiers nous
avons principe de formation donc si le
bon bout on va vous trouver plus des
formations de l'industrie le sud des
bruits vous aurez toutes les formations
de l'artisanat dont fait partie la voix
de pierre destic
l'arrière également de l'industrie et le
sud de mafieux où vous n'aurez plus
particulièrement les plantations du
capitaine donc on propose plus 90
formations différentes allant du cp
jusqu'au bac 5
nous travaillons en partenariat avec des
entreprises nous évoquerons les
apprentis et je pense quand on va
détailler un peu plus précisément sur la
la prochaine spy 2 voilà comment
s'organise l'apprentissage donc le
niveau du public à savoir que ça
s'adresse à un public de jeunes qui va
de 15 avant
tout dans un champ a dépendu des
dérogations possibles pour les moins de
15 ans et les plus de 29 ans si vous
avez besoin de précisions sur une femme
voilà des choses plus précises sur ça
peut-être que nous pourra en profiter
pour poser vos questions à leur chatte
ensuite concernant donc la formation en
alternance comment ça s'organise donc
une partie théorique qui se fait au sein
et une partie pratique qui va se faire
en entreprise est un système deux jours
d'alternance nous sur notre formation
donc en voiture et en esthétique on est
sur deux jours et trois entreprises
alors au niveau de tout à l'heure je
vous disais donc il y avait une
rémunération pour la formation en
alternance on signe un contrat
d'apprentissage du foot - un contrat de
professionnalisation donc là vous voyez
apparaissent quand un slide de nam la
répartition de la rémunération en fait
c'est un pourcentage du smic il a varié
en fonction de l'âge de l'apprenti de
l'année de formation
et de la convention collective par
exemple la voiture rentre également une
demande de diplômes préparés
ensuite au niveau du contrat
d'apprentissage donc la rémunération en
fait aussi en profondeur pour 30 années
de smic mais avec d'autres variables
puisqu'il c'est une fonction de l'âge de
l'apprenti et des dom a déjà obtenu
alors on va vous proposer
d'ailleurs petit quizz maintenant
à vous de à vous de répondre le petit
nice on vous pose cette question savez
vous combien d'apprentis nouvelle chef
d'entreprise après leurs études
est-ce que c'est son sang qu'est ce que
c'est important
et moi
vous avez répondu
vous avez vous vu 20% la plupart de peau
et bien vous avez raison les avez raison
effectivement 50 % des apprentis
deuxième chef dans le fait avec nous
après leurs effets bravo
bienvenue dans le plus grand centre de
formation d'un terminus du sud
francilien la faculté des métiers de
l'essonne c'est 90 formations gratuites
et rémunérées du crp au bac + 5 dans
huit filières métiers répartis sur trois
sites
la faculté des métiers de l'essonne
accompagne chaque année 3000 apprentis
et cinq mille stagiaires de la formation
continue vers des parcours
professionnels réussi et de réelles
opportunités d'emploi en effet avec un
réseau de 2000 entreprises partenaires
elle affiche un taux d'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 80%
sur le site d'evry courcouronnes la
filière beauté bien-être propose de
formation en coiffure et en esthétique
d'anciens apprentis aujourd'hui salarié
ou chefs d'entreprises et des apprentis
actuellement en formation témoignent de
leur expérience
j'ai choisi l'alternance parce que pour
moi c'est une liberté autant
financièrement parlant que même au
niveau de la pratique on peut exercer
beaucoup plus facilement notre métier
quand on est et à l'école et un salon
c'est vraiment le plus du cfa on apprend
mieux on est plus sur le terrain devient
plus mature c'est pas évident de trouver
des bons professeurs qui prennent leur
métier à coeur ici j'ai eu la chance
d'en trouver ils aiment ce qu'ils font
ils ont vraiment envie que leurs élèves
réussissent dans les moments où j'avais
des doutes au niveau de mon orientation
je savais pas trop quel chemin emprunter
j'ai toujours pu me confier à des profs
qui m'ont vraiment aidé conforté dans
mes choix c'est un bel endroit les
professeurs sont très gentils ils vous
épaules jusqu'au bout il vous aide et
c'est très agréable de venir apprendre
ici on a tous les équipements
professionnels les casques les banques
coiffage les bacs donc c'est vraiment
tout comme un salon de coiffure mais
pour l'apprentissage j'ai envie de
transmettre mon savoir faire à mes
apprentis pour qu'elle puisse évoluer
les faire grandir à leur tour j'ai gardé
de très bons contacts avec ma
professeure de pratique je les petites
interventions pour parler de mon
parcours professionnel avec ses élèves
donc c'est j'aime beaucoup
si tu es deux pas de la gare rer est
organisée autour des espaces verts
arborés le campus d'evry de la faculté
des mythes et l'essonne propose des
équipements dédiés moderne et performant
deux amphithéâtres
un restaurant d'application ouvert au
public sur réservation un centre de
ressources
et un complexe sportif
deux espaces de restauration sont à
votre disposition
self et cafétérias enfin la faculté des
métiers de l'essonne dispose d'un
service d'accès à l'alternance proposant
notamment une prépa apprentissage et
permettant à la faculté des métiers
l'essonne d'être fiers d'intégrer tout
type de handicap alors n'hésitez pas
rejoignez nous
donc nous allons vous présenter
du coup plus précisément maintenant les
métiers de la coiffure et de
l'esthétique on se permet de sourire
parce que les aléas du direct font que
nous parlions dans le vide visiblement
mais on recommence ne vous inquiétez pas
on est là pour ça donc donc on va vous
présenter les professeurs et donc les
jeunes apprentis qui nous fait l'honneur
de nous rejoindre on vous présentait il
allait métier qu'ils ont choisi et pour
les jeunes leur parcours
donc
nous allons parler en détails d'une été
visités de la voiture donc on se disait
c'est un métier passion parce que vous
rentrez en intimité avec la clientèle
d'avoir enfin
on est dans mon métier de luxe dans les
prestations qui sont onéreuses donc
quand une antenne à temps aux
arrondissements
insertion des besoins de besoins de la
clientèle
c'est un métier vraiment s'adapter à la
clientèle pour la prison de laon traces
de soi d'un pouvoir de la communication
de l'impact il est devenu professionnel
la vitrine en fait le secteur beauté
coiffure et en esthétique et à cette
vitrine halles c'est comme ça rassurez
vous
alors vous les jeunes qu'est ce qui vous
a amené quel est votre parcours qui les
a amenés vers des métiers
alors moi en effet actuellement
quant à lui en faisait le guet apens
dans
[Musique]
l'apprentissage assurant du coup que
c'était pas du tout que je voulais faire
la médiation les changes personnes en
général ainsi que 11 points
mais sexy que le choix se passe comme si
les affaires d'un constat de maeterlinck
avec directement et l'a23 de nous
rassurer a battu deux fois
comme ça
alors pour ma part j'ai commencé
en suivant le décès de ma mère je suis
parti dans l'équipe d'éducateurs
spécialisés je fais à peine six mois
j'étais
bien et j'ai écouté ce que je voulais
faire moi même en recentrant utile que
sur notre intérêt est ce que j'ai donc
fait le choix de me prouver en brevet
professionnel en voiture
qui voulait en fait tous les deux en
fait ce choix
moi j'ai changé avec la trempette pour
important de troubles et appartenance il
est comme moi qui avait changé lorsque
vous faites tout le monde a tourné à
procéder
avec l'expert
accidentelle et qu'il affronte ce
dimanche
je rejoins un peu ce que tu dis mais je
vais ajouter aussi le côté de liberté
c'est vrai que mon sens du cadre
scolaire on aller entre le professionnel
de l'école les artichauts en bo1 réussir
à faire la part de choses mais
et
donc débouché et mon cerveau soit
on apprenait mettre en pratique
le deux des caméras que j'ai très hâte
d'aller choisir
votre côté en tant que format tout ça
qu'est-ce que vous
avez apprécié en fait pour reconnaissez
dans les élèves qui rejoindra régulière
en faire
alors pour avoir commis les deux sera
uniquement
toujours en cours en présentiel et pour
faire de 15 ans de l'apprentissage pour
moi il ya une énorme différence parce
que lorsque on a des jeunes en face aux
knicks sur l'apprentissage
et leur cependant lorsqu'il y en a nous
avons en face de nous re en
apprentissage
on a des personnes qui connaissent
davantage le métier parce que 50% du
temps ces jeunes sont en entreprise
l'avantagent aussi c'était un réel
échange entre nos jeunes et nous parce
que comme il son coeur du métier il ya
beaucoup de nouvelles techniques de
nouveaux appareils et du coup il ya un
véritable échange entre les formateurs
et les apprentis il ya beaucoup plus de
maturité professionnelle
nous on a des jeunes ont des suis
souvent du sap et au brevet
professionnel voire en bts et on voit
une très très belle évolution de nos
jeunes
durant ces deux ans quatre ans six ans
de formation à la faculté des métiers
donc c'est vrai que cette évolution
grandissante
pendant ces différentes années ça nous
apporte aussi une grande satisfaction
professionnelle et de voir nos jeunes
qui de nous revoir aussi après toutes
ces années pour nous expliquer leur
parcours professionnel
parfois certains d'entre eux sont
devenus
formateur certains d'entre eux sont
devenus patrons d'entreprises et nous
prennent à des apprentis donc c'est vrai
que c'est une grande satisfaction
professionnelle de voir les jeunes comme
s'agrandir et très bien développé alors
je demande c'est l'occasion d'aller un
peu plus loin dans le parc aura deux
formations alors voilà donc là on va
vous présenter le parcours de formation
continue pour poser a donc au cfa donc
pour les formations qui se font en
alternance
donc vous avez bien expliquer à quel
moment vous pouvez intégrer telle ou
telle formation faut que si on prend par
exemple on commence par les débuts après
la classe de troisième
donc on vous proposait le ca brive
coiffure qui se fera en deux ans
et également donc le capc tic qui se
fera en deux ans donc alors pour vous
expliquer brièvement les différents sur
chaque diplôme il faut retenir en fait
que ça soit pour la coiffure ou
l'esthétique ans et après vous allez
apprendre toutes les bases du métier
ensuite en brevet professionnel plus de
perfectionnement donc après si vous avez
besoin voilà de renseignements plus
précis sur le métier de la coiffure ou
l'esthétique
n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos questions
on y répondra plus en détail je pense à
la fin de la présentation donc après le
servait en deux ans vous avez
possibilité d'intégrer le brevet
professionnel c'est également en deux
ans donc le bp coiffure et le dp ce titi
après le ca fait en deux ans avant
d'intégrer en fait un brevet
professionnel en coiffure vous pouvez
passer par la mention complémentaire
qui se fait sur une année de formation
qui est spécialisée en fait dans la pure
coupe et couleur ou le gars très peu
d'enseignement général mais c'est plus
une formation
plus technique
vous voyez apparaître également le ca
paix en un an donc le servait un an il
est accessible à partir du moment où
vous avez déjà un diplôme donc soit un
ca fait dans un autre métier ou un
baccalauréat dans le servait un an en
fait vous n'aurez pas du tout
d'enseignement général ça sera est
essentiellement voilà des cours de
pratique et de l'enseignement
professionnels
et après donc le servait en un an ou le
brevet professionnel que ça soit en
toiture en esthétique vous pouvez
poursuivre encore pendant deux ans en
faisant le bts
voilà ce qu'on peut vous expliquer
brièvement sur le parcours de par nation
vous à vos parcours
d'avoir un vidéo professionnelle
utile dans la vie professionnelle pour
obtenir un emploi
alors on vous propose un quiz and ouvre
donc
l'apprentissage est réservée aux élèves
qui ne peuvent pas continuer leurs
études en enseignement général ou qui ne
sont pas motivés continuer leurs études
c'est faux d'appeler
vous abreu l'ufoa 75% et bien vous avez
raison a effectivement les jeunes
voulons bien expliqué il s'agit d'un
métier passion avant tout avec le lien
des niveaux en fait qu'ils sont
suffisamment étoffé pour
plaire à ceux qui veulent faire des
études et ceux qui préfèrent habitent
loin et du côté ps donc effectivement
ce n'est absolument pas échappé aux
élèves
en échec scolaire
alors nous avons avec nous
nous avons avec nous donc ces six là
comme je vous disais qui est donc
médiatrice de l'apprentissage qui est là
pour vous donner bien les conseils qui
peuvent permettre qu'ils vont nous
permettre de vivre vient vivre votre vie
d'apprendre cécile
je le prouve un monde
ils vous mentent et bien c'est bon
alors oui je
trois conseils de questions on pêche
important pour
bien enclenché on va dire
votre votre apprentissage parce que
c'est pas simple quand on arrive dans
l'apprentissage comme ça de sortir de
l'école de 3e et finalement être être
employés et salariés d'une entreprise
mais c'est pas simple donc effectivement
voilà trois petits conseils qui nous
paraissent qui me paraissent importants
pour éventuellement vous aider à bien
d'empêcher cet apprentissage
en et je pense que c'est vraiment plus
important c'est de montrer sa motivation
ça englobe pas mal de choses ça englobe
la ponctualité par exemple voilà il
comme comme vous faisiez à l'école
effectivement pour garder sa note cette
bonne habitude vous êtes effectivement
vraiment vous le rappeler que vous êtes
salarié et que vous êtes
payé elles vont effectivement la
ponctualité
est primordial effectivement change tout
vous faites partie d'une équipe d'une
équipe donc le travail et l'entreprise
finalement ne va pas vous attendre donc
c'est important de
montrer sa motivation en étant
ponctuelles en étant
en étant poli voilà montrez-nous bonne
volonté vous avez tout à fait droit de
vous tromper vous êtes là pour apprendre
donc donc voilà vous avez tout à fait le
droit de vous tromper la seule chose
c'est qu'effectivement il faut que vous
montriez que vous avez envie si vous
aviez à des choses effectivement qui
sont finies va redemander quelque chose
est ce que c'est ce que j'ai bien fait
si ce que j'ai bien fait ça voilà ça
fait parti de montrer sa motivation
voilà ça sera un petit conseil qui mange
pas de pain mais qu'effectivement et
s'avère s'avère très important pour bien
commencer
pour bien commencer son à fond
le deuxième point qui est et reste très
important qui est qui revient
globalement
dans les comptes
à régler à voir c'est tout ça le
sèche-cheveux essayer de se placer au
maximum de son téléphone portable alors
j'espère que ça s'est compliqué pour
vous pour nous déjà deux c'est compliqué
mais alors pour vous c'est encore pire
et on en est bien conscient vous êtes né
avec ce que votre troisième main et
[Musique]
c'est normal maintenant il faut voilà il
faut faire vraiment des efforts là
dessus essayez voilà de s'en passer un
maximum
vous aurez de l'institut redéposent
comme à l'école de la même manière
pour pour reprendre votre portable
voilà c'est important et puis
effectivement
si vous êtes effectivement à regarder
votre portable professionnellement vous
allez pas être forcément concentré
voilà et puis ça se fait pas
effectivement en entreprise comme à
l'école donc vraiment garder cette bonne
habitude parce que c'est vraiment un
conflit qui revient l'employeur c'est
pas un
informateur donc il n'est pas là pour
elle derrière vous avoue flic est donc
vraiment s'il le voit une fois deux fois
trois fois ça va lagacé et puis du coup
il va être moins agréables avec vous et
puis ensuite vous vous allez pas trop
comprendre et vie voilà et puis les
conflits commence comme ça c'est tout
voilà c'est des petits soucis comme ça
qui peuvent être facilement
évités
donc voilà c'est un deuxième conseil qui
est
selon moins important pour bien
enclenché son apprentissage et puis
quand vous allez reprendre votre
portable après à la pause ou à les avoir
plein de messages est pour et pour la
satisfaction personnelle vous allez voir
ça sera super
et le troisième point c'est
effectivement sollicité des échanges
avec son maître d'apprentissage
alors je m'explique surtout surtout au
début effectivement parce que c'est pas
simple des techniques pour vous valez
salariés un petit peu de jours au
lendemain de s'auto-évaluer en
entreprise de savoir les points
effectivement à améliorer les points où
on a pêché les points où on est plutôt
vont
tous les cfa ne fonctionne pas
exactement de la même manière mais
généralement c'est une semaine une
semaine l'entreprise d'une semaine école
ou deux semaines l'entreprise de semaine
école moi ce que je vous invite à faire
dès le début c'est de prendre cinq
minutes même si c'est pas très très long
de prendre juste cinq minutes à la fin
de votre de votre semaine
d'entreprise avant de regagner l'école
de faire un point avec votre maître
d'apprentissage de cinq petites minutes
pour savoir en groupe à ce qui a été ce
qui n'a pas été
voilà faire un point ce peut-être s'auto
évaluer et avoir un petit peu de recul
sur sur soi et puis voilà vous allez
instaurer du coup un échange un
relationnel avec lui une complicité
pourquoi pas
voilà donc c'est vraiment un conseil qui
est pour moi très important et je vous
invite à effectivement à le mot a gardé
tout au long de la course si c'est
possible ou en tout cas au moins au
début effectivement je trouve que c'est
important de trouver ce petit temps avec
son maître d'apprentissage
ça peut-être encourageant aussi puisque
le maître d'apprentissage pourra vous
dire ce qui va ce qu'ils attendent à
apprécier la musique et à améliorer
fantasme devant fabien problèmes à maman
et si c'est pas mignon en place des
départs par le maître d'apprentissage
parce que forcément on les dit on pas
forcément le temps je n'ai pas forcément
un tas de raisons
n'hésitez pas à le solliciter n'hésitez
pas à lui réclamer ce petit temps ces
cinq minutes ça sera jamais mal perçu
jamais au contraire voilà merci à merci
beaucoup 6 il a alors on va passer
effectivement
des atouts des plus pratiques à savoir
qu'elles sont bien les informations les
procédures d'inscription pour intégrer
donc centre de formation d'apprentis
alors au vu de cette procédure
d'inscription dans le développement de
la formation en emploi pour choisir
votre formation mais en fait vous avez
plusieurs possibilités
ce soin de vous rendre directement sur
notre site internet vous voyez l'adresse
inscrite là vous pourrez pas choisir
votre formation paragraphe amour au
diplôme d'état
vous aurez également la possibilité de
venir découvrir nos informations lors de
nos jeux on n'est pas ouverte notre
prochaine
journée portes ouvertes au cfa aura lieu
samedi prochain donc de 9 heures à 17
heures ce sera l'occasion de visiter
notre établissement de visiter les
ateliers de pratique de rencontrer des
formateurs voilà meetic pourront
également faire des programmes de métier
donc une fois que vous aurez fait ce
choix de formation il suffit que vous
pré inscrire en ligne donc vous voyez un
peu comment ça se présente
donc il suffit de cliquer sur le petit
bouton se préinscrire donc là vous
arriverez sur une page où il faudra
remplir certains enseignements donc
surtout soyez bien vigilant par rapport
aux documents qu'il faudra fournir
puisqu'on aura besoin voilà de tous les
justes de document qui sera affichée ça
sera vraiment des documents obligatoires
à nous transmettre
à l'issue de cette formation de cette
inscription pardon vous allez recevoir
vos identifiants sur une plate forme qui
vous permettra de de mettre à jour votre
fumant de pouvoir échanger avec le cf
jusqu'à ce que vous trouviez en fait
votre employeur donc nous pour trouver
votre employeur en fait le cfa est là
pour vous aider à vous l'aurez plusieurs
personnes à votre disposition donc on
commencera déjà par un entretien
individuel
pendant lequel on validera avec vous
votre choix de formation on vous
apportera justement des conseils pour
votre chef d'entreprise
vous pourrez vous inscrire donc à des
ateliers tr eux ce sont des ateliers de
techniques de recherche d'entreprise ils
seront donc animés par des personnes du
sel avec des personnes professionnels
pendant en fait envie les ateliers
pendant lesquelles on va vous aider à
faire votre lettre de motivation nova
puis avec une habilité à vous mettre en
contact également avec les entreprises
qui recrutent
pour voilà le but de toute cette
procédure c'est de vous accompagner au
mieux à votre choix de formation et à
votre signature
vous
demandez quand on sait que la recherche
d'emploi il est toujours un moment de
bien compliqué à gérer un peu angoissant
aussi on aime les femmes tendent à part
toi qui fais pas la faire justement je
voulais vous demander tous les deux là
comment vous avez fait pour trouver
l'employeur qui aujourd'hui conforme
j'ai cherché un mardi j'ai un avis
mais si je peux le faire par
nicolas et les policiers
beaucoup de rois de la soul y chercher
l'information sur internet
on pourra pas disent pas leur nom
et leur situation
l'événement vient présenter je n'ai rien
dit avoir une autre posture parler
correctement l'écran
est un peu
curieuse et d'autre axel
assurant il pense maintenir si on sait
pas tenir a continué à chercher parce
que patrick
ratineaud sentait venir ça veut dire
quand même que tout dépassement envoie
les impayés
se déplacer c'est important de suicides
est alors moi pour ma part j'avais eu
mes recherches en parallèle à la voie
nos cv lettre de motivation à sa
compagne et parfois on a la chance
d'avoir des réponses assez rapidement et
puis là
on apportera avec lui simplement et
aussi pourquoi même continué ses
recherches en parallèle parce que
le patron russe c'est un travail des tic
en faire et voilà on reste en contact
pendant toute la période
de recherche d'entreprise jusqu'à la
signature de
l'intérieur poser votre chiot je crois
que le fait qu'il ait quand même payer
en trop de difficulté même s'il faut
faire un effort va évidemment de
présentation et
d'expression
ce que je bois offre des perspectives de
déchets clairement
brendan porter aujourd'hui
les apprentis font partie de la vie de
l'entreprise l'anac dans la peinture et
les arts les plus importants le premier
challenge est fort tout le monde
tournait pour les maîtres
d'apprentissage d'une forme les jeunes
les former à leur tour devient grand
maître d'apprentissage certainement et
bien c'est un thème qui fonctionne bien
et on aime bien le père du est avec vous
pour la suite alors quelques
informations pratiques
avant de passer au bon moment
alors donc vont l'accueillir pour cette
année vous avez les dates avec les gens
n'est pas ouverte donc comme vous
expliquer la prochaine j'en ai partout 9
au cfa aura lieu samedi 5 février de 9h
à 17h ça sera l'occasion voilà de
rencontrer les formateurs de pratiques
de visiter des ateliers
de voilà de pouvoir échanger côté vos
questions vous aider dans votre
procédure d'inscription vous avez
ensuite donc il y aura la grève du bus
max arrête la journée et ensuite 2 2
millions et vente de matinée devrait
ramener de 20 et vous aurez également la
possibilité de venir on a creusé
d'apprentissage donc ils vont démarrer
la main à partir du 16 février voilà
vous avez fait date et s'affiche tout en
sachant de ces journées portes ouvertes
et notre ami d'apprentissage monde
auront lieu donc sur les principes de la
petite minute lors de ma formation
pratique aussi pour maison des époux
avait des personnes infectées donc la
faculté d mais j'ai alors douté tic au
niveau de la personne qui va s'occuper
de la partie administrative c'est à dire
inscription préparation du contrat et
c'est madame alexandra rosello vous avez
son numéro de téléphone direct et son
adresse mail sur le même poste mais en
voiture cela n'absout fiable ou sans
arrêt avec ses coordonnées de moi même
en tant que chargée de développement et
la responsable de la filière artisanale
qui regroupe donc la voiture
d'esthétique et les métiers de bouche
c'est madame vergy micro vous avez ces
corps
alors que vous avez toutes les infos
d'un coup d'envoi est donné c'est la
pratique
dont vous avez effectivement posé audois
actuellement deux questions insolites
chaque
est il possible de débuter un s'est
affaissé tic à 14 ans alors très bonne
question puisque tout à l'heure on a
évoqué justement l'âge pour démarrer sa
formation il faut savoir que le contrat
en tissage peut être signés à partir de
15 ans en ayant achevé son cycle
scolaire donc
impossible de signer un contrat
d'apprentissage à 14 ans il faudra
attendre d'avoir 15 ans et d'avoir été
jusqu'à la fin de la troisième
est venue des plafonds de prix qui
permette une transition jolie vrai cap
aura marant il y avait le pré
apprentissage mais n'existe plus donc la
rapide j'ai passé un autre dispositif ma
connaissance non donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment attendre d'avoir 15 ans
pour démarrer la formation alterne alors
parfois ce qu'il est toujours possible
de faire ce sont des stages pendant les
vacances scolaires décidé mais qui vous
amuser et pendant les vacances scolaires
vous savez que en troisième
effectivement il ya un stage obligatoire
va un petit peu sur le même sur le même
principe donc ce soit obligatoire bien
sûr vous avez la possibilité de faire
entre un et cinq jours de stage dans une
entreprise
bas pour pour observer tester voire
mondial évidemment c'est pas évident
très directe 1 encore dans
l'apprentissage mais ça permet de vous
comporter en fait ou pas éventuellement
dans le choix initial visait qu'à 14 ans
les très jeunes donc c'est vrai qu'on a
eu l'idée de son père n'était pas
forcément toujours bien la première
n'est pas forcément la bonne a donc
testé sur le terrain je pense que c'est
une bonne solution pour attendre bien
ses 15 ans et puis pouvoir s'y est
toujours bien continuer à travailler
finalement au collège parce qu'en fin de
troisième sa planète en fait vous allez
lui puisque si vous allez en vendent pas
et vous pouvez commencer votre
apprentissage à 15 ans on
vous rappelle c'est que s'il n'avait pas
été vu comme le troisième vous devez pas
commencé à 15 ans pour atteindre c'est
donc vraiment que vous restiez et que
vous conduisez a
étudié au collège
jusqu'au bout de votre iphone ou de
votre troisième alors une autre question
à nous a été posée est il possible de
suivre un bac professionnel esthétique
après la troisième
alors est la faculté des métiers
aujourd'hui le cursus qu'on propose
c'est de ces ap et le brevet
professionnel donc le ca paix a pris la
3è ça se fait en deux ans et de brevet
professionnel derrière ça se fait
également deux ans voilà aujourd'hui à
la faculté des métiers nous ne proposons
pas le bac professionnel
nous restons plutôt sur le brevet
professionnel
pourquoi c'est un choix volontaire
parce que
en connaissant les deux diplômes le bac
professionnel est axé plus un aspect
théorique
le brevet professionnel et aspect plus
sur l'aspect pratique et nous c'est ce
qu'on met en avant aujourd'hui la
faculté des métiers voilà donc c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui après la
troisième vous proposera un ca paix en
deux ans en alternance bien sûr et
ensuite un brevet professionnel
alors en terme de niveau il faut quand
même relevé que le brevet professionnel
est exactement au même niveau que le
directement professionnel il n'y a pas
l'ombre qui est supérieur à lyon on est
vraiment sur deux diplômes différents à
l'origine en termes de contenu est par
contre en terme de niveau une vraie
professionnelle les antiques à celui qui
va qu'à lauréats du baccalauréat
professionnel et le brevet professionnel
permet la poursuite d'études tout autant
que le vague professionnel ouvert vers
un bts et je continue dans la vente à
filière lait je me permets d'ajouter
vous pour faire dévier l'entreprise
régulièrement avec la dame journal nous
les ressentis qu'on a au niveau de nos
maîtres d'apprentissage des employeurs
c'est que brevet professionnel est un
diplôme qui est très reconnu le plus
reconnu certainement parce que justement
les jeunes sont tout est axé sur
l'aspect pratique et donc il est très
très très reconnu dans le domaine
professionnel
il est très recherché
demande de passer à la troisième de
faire avoir la possibilité de faire une
spéciale sans est-ce que c'était pas ça
la question
le troisième c'est obligé de faire un ca
fait avant d'aller en brevet
professionnel parce que comme l'a
expliqué tout à leurs malades fournol le
capc la base du métier vous allez
apprendre toutes les bases en termes
d'hygiène d'ergonomie sécurité de
techniques d'appareils de connaissances
ou cosmétologiques vous allez apprendre
la base du métier et le brevet
professionnel c'est un perfectionnement
des techniques que vous n'aurez pas bien
sapés sont très professionnalisante cdp
qnx ont demandé aujourd'hui sur le
marché du travail et le diplôme du
brevet professionnel elle a été rénovée
récemment et il colle parfaitement avec
ce qui est demandé aujourd'hui en
entreprise donc c'est pour ça qu'il est
très recherchées par les employeurs
alors il ya aussi peut-être un point
important a ajouté c'est qu'à partir du
moment où vous souhaitez vous installer
à votre compte c'est à dire ouvrir votre
propre salon de coiffure faut savoir que
le bourreau des professionnels est
obligatoire alors qu'on pourra être un
match n'a pas de souci à ce niveau là
puisque c'est du même niveau mais il est
important
de souligner que le diplôme est le seul
le seul moyen pour ouvrir son salon en
tout cas sans d'embaucher quelqu'un qui
est là en esthétique c'est un petit peu
différent mais qu'il voulait s'expliquer
en esthétique avec un ciel peu
esthétique vous avez la possibilité
d'ouvrir
un institut de beauté par contre en
coiffure en coiffure en fait il est
important d'avoir un brevet
professionnel parce qu'on avait pu quand
même des produits chimiques concile
d'avoir problème des connaissances
professionnelles et approfondie afin de
pouvoir engager la sécurité du client et
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu en tout cas il
est impératif d'avoir un brevet
professionnel pour pouvoir être sérieux
et dans les règles pour pouvoir assurer
la sécurité du camp parce qu'encore une
fois ce qui est des produits chimiques
on ne rigole pas avec ça
c'est vrai et dans ces aussi une
législation existe
depuis fort longtemps je pense que pour
des professionnels qui soit esthétique
coiffure est un diplôme de toute façon
qui sera reconnu et apprécié aujourd'hui
fait d'ailleurs
mais clairement effectivement bas si
vous souhaitez vous installer
ou absolument décrocher le sait a perdu
clip voulait plus pourquoi furent pour
être tranquille en quelques pour pouvoir
être autonome en tout cas dans sa
gestion d'entreprise est ce que tous les
deux est ce que c'était un des éléments
à des
conditions qui ont fait que vous avez
choisi de faire ce titre là vous
installez un jour le dernier objectif au
début après mes objectifs ont évolué de
rinne avec le service correctionnel lui
l'objectif de la paix
en moi appartenant à la ville sonatrach
est sur un professionnel parce que le
band du tout anachronisme
les
choses nous avons dit aux professionnels
ont été
perfectionnées
assez bien
et est ce que le salaire du coup va
payer aux diplômes à que vous devez
respecter et que le mondial
non sans doute panne ça dépend surtout
de la veille à des particularités sont
l'esthétique
entendu de cause uniquement lahj et
dhaleh temps la passion exprès
l'apprenti tracé a fait un bébé ou on
déteste ça se passe bien taux de
rémunération alors en voiture il ya le
diplôme qui intervient par exemple un
apprenti du même âge qui fasse un ca t1
des témoins des tests il va être
rémunéré
une rémunération différentes
voilà et c'est vrai que sur la voiture
il y avait une convention collective
avec des accords de branche qui
favorisera un salaire plus élevé les
autres formations
au moins cinq mille deux cents de plus
par rapport aux autres formations ou
plus le fait de faire un différend au
gran caribe narration pendant la période
d'apprentissage tout à fait par la suite
alors après on était égal et comme il ya
les les conventions collectives qui vont
fixer voilà des rémunérations avec des
avantages différents
parler des objectifs
au démarrage des apprentis en fait faut
savoir qu'au fur et à mesure du point
qu'ils évoluent dans le domaine de
l'esthétique aux voitures du coup ils
découvrent aussi d'autres aspects du
métier notamment du père pour lorenzo
qui m'a attirée par entrepreneuriat en
fait il se raconte que dans le métier de
la coiffure il ya aussi d'autres
domaines dire artistique donc du groupe
qui sont aussi possibles on n'est pas
obligé de travailler dans un institut ou
dans un salon mais du coup on se rend
compte faire plusieurs ouvertures
possibles liés à ces démarrages de
formation ok alors votre autre question
provoque a été posée quelles sont les
horaires
donc du lycée donc je pense que c'est du
coup en formation
pour les belem alors de savoir que les
contrat d'apprentissage france en 5h30
dans ses 35 heures en fait vous avez
liste des écoles et les entreprises et
les hauts niveaux de la terre
d'inspiration en patients industrie tig
on est deux jours et votre agent
entreprises et les horaires alors les
journées de pratique sont des journées
de 7 heures et les journées
d'enseignement de général de
l'enseignement professionnel s'est
désolé de six heures donc voilà plus
tout dépend si vous êtes sur un terrain
et un an ou deux ans il y aura des
nombres d'heures par semaine dit
somnifère
est ce qu'il faut retenir voilà c'est
aujourd'hui de 7 heures pour la fatigue
six heures pendant un an en général et
ce à deux jours personnel
alors une autre qu'elle peut déposer
pouvez vous nous dire pour bien d'élèves
par classe en perdre les coiffures et
ont fait appel
alors aujourd'hui on a on travaille en
2000 groupe et ça c'est la force aussi
la faculté des métiers c'est à dire que
lorsque les apprentis sont en pratique
on accueille dès 2000 groupe est donc un
groupe est composé de quatorze apprentis
dans la correction en classe entière et
128 maximum est donc en cours de
pratique pendant les secteurs de 36 cas
c'est quatorze apprentis donc l'avantagé
aussi c'est que on a un travail qui est
très très personnalisé et on peut
vraiment cadres et les jeunes parce que
justement on a eu peu d'apprentis devant
nous il ya un peu du coup faciliter
aussi des échanges et des questions
c'est beaucoup plus facile
alors
premier vous d'autres questions
n'hésitez pas en fait
naturellement
quelques minutes
vous permet de parcourir
d'état pouvoirs publics
voulaient voir
veut nous envoyer le port alors en fait
les présentations seront accessibles sur
le site de la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat de des sols donc
de taper sur n'importe quel moteur de
recherche cm à 81 poussait emerson et
donc vous pourrez accéder accéder du
coup aussi de la chambre de métiers et
dans la rubrique apprentissage vous
retrouverez en fait les présentations et
même bien d'autres informations des
documents sur les métiers vous
retrouverez également les vidéos qui a
été présenté sachant aussi que bien été
comme
ou là on vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
vous pouvez aller dès samedi à visiter
la faculté des métiers a pour sa journée
portes ouvertes est debout
je pense que rien ne vaut
la discussion quand on le peut sur place
en direct avec les personnes présentes
et surtout visiter les classes de
pratique je crois que c'est ce qui
permet de voir très précisément
à une réplique à reese et moi je
m'arrête parce que jacky nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps et on a une question
importante quelle est la rémunération
en apprentissage alors les nations ont
pesé pour revenir sur la lie de tableau
qui explique en fait c'est un
pourcentage du smic
qui varient voilà en fonction de l'âge
de l'année de formation
donc ça c'est que ça sera
essentiellement pour les formations en
esthétique et après quand nous les
expliquer pour la coiffure il ya le
diplôme qui rentrent également en ligne
de compte
alors si et on va pas reprendre
peut-être tous les barèmes de
rémunérations il ya une tranche d'âge
donc les moins de 18 ans un certain
pourcentage du smic
ensuite vous avez la tranche d'âge de 18
à 20 ans 21 à 25 ans et plus de 26 ans
donc là vous voyez apparaître les
pourcentage du smic tout en sachant que
ce sont des rémunérations son butin mais
qui sont exonérés pratiquement à 100 des
charges donc le montant
que vous obtiendrez en calculant voilà
le prochain stage ça vous donnera
pratiquement la rémunération nette que
vous percevrez tous les mois
il faut savoir ensuite viendra en
déduction
la cotisation de l'habituel
dans votre entreprise et si vous
utilisez les transports en commun voilà
vous serez remboursé à la moitié de
votre titre de transport
elle a rappelé en parlant toujours de
rémunération ou dette financière c'est
vrai ça c'est peut-être un bon point
pour le dise que poursuivre formation de
s'asseoir en esthétique il faut prévoir
de l'achat de matériel
alors il faut savoir que la faculté des
métiers
ne servent pas vous offre pendant vos
années de formation tout ce qui est
produits
consommables après
cependant
vous allez vous avez besoin d'un type de
rentrée voilà donc ce qui te rend très
en esthétique il ya deux types
différents il ya un kit maquillage avec
un partenariat en partenariat avec
lesquels on travaille sergio alvarez et
on travaille également un probiotique
institut donc il prend les produits de
besoin de matériel donc il ya un type de
rentrée qui est autour de 700 euros
voilà on s'est appelé et 2 500 euros en
bété à peu près voilà donc c'est un type
qui est
qui est nécessaire pour pouvoir
travailler correctement
avec
l'âge le matériel
dans de bonnes conditions grand dans vos
années de formation
ce qu'ils peuvent pour l'ensemble alors
le en ont certainement séance et ap donc
un kit avoir en début d'année qui va là
pour l'heure deux ans de formation et en
brevet professionnel
il y à un deuxième titre complémentaire
au crb parce qu'on vous des
professionnels en cette promotion des
techniques plus perfectionnés et donc il
ya eu du coup un deuxième type d'avoir
envie de bébé est ensuite bien sûr
valade sur les besoins des dons pour la
première c'est la même chose on a un kit
de base qui va vous dire est malgré tout
besoin d'autres formations sont assez ap
bp et par contre effectivement chaque
année va falloir ajouter des têtes mal
être que du coup est parti aussi de la
formation c'est sur ces fameuses lettres
on s'entraînera lors des cours pratiques
et cauvin naturellement comme on sait où
on est on sait leers à faire des coupes
de site à site des colorations donc du
coup la maison du pain à la longueur
s'amenuiser d'andokoua falloir un
réassort de d'être malade mais en tout
cas c'est compris vraiment pour l'année
complète et à la rentrée pour l'année
complète
de l'otan la raison en est que savoir
que le il ya une possibilité de se faire
rembourser jusqu'à 500 euros en
fournissant les factures d'achat
de lacharrière
écoutez je pense qu'on aurait pu doubler
les informations dont vous aviez besoin
pour bien faire faire un choix
d'orientation à l'objectif pour
d'aujourd'hui quand vous l'avez bien
compris c'est de vous donner matière à
réfléchir sur l'orientation que vous
souhaiteriez prendre n'hésitez surtout
pas comme
vous disais bien aller aux journées
portes ouvertes où j'ai dû doigt et voir
réellement et bien les les
classes de pratique surtout qu'ils aient
pu discuter bien sûr sur place avec les
personnes présentes vous peur des gens
n'est pas recouvert qui commence donc
dès samedi et il ya revoir voir et
revoir
les les powerpoint qui vous ce qui vous
sont présentés le jour voilà on vous
salue et je remercie vivement donc la
faculté d'héritiers les apprentis
formateur
développeurs qui ont bien voulu nous
accompagner aujourd'hui et vous
accompagner dans le choix de votre
orientation à bientôt